مرحبًا بكم في مطعم ساشا ، تقول
أن ساشا فقط لم تعد موجودة ولا توجد أي
من الشقق في هذا المبنى فوق
طاولة طعام وكراسي سترة
تهب في مهب الريح لا تزال سليمة
التذكير المرئي الوحيد للعائلات
التي عاشت هنا
قلب الغربان فوق هذه المدينة  من
borodianka ربما شعروا بالموت
هنا ،
فمن الواضح أن الدمار الهائل
يقع في الغالب على طول الشارع الرئيسي ،
ويبدو أن الأعمدة المدرعة الروسية
انفتحت ببساطة بالمدافع الرشاشة
الثقيلة والمدفعية أثناء توغلها عبر
المدينة
لبنة لبنة اليوم ، وبدأت عملية الحفر في
محاولة  العثور على مدنيين أو جثثهم
مدفونة تحت الأنقاض حتى عندما
تم تحويل ملاجئهم في الطابق السفلي إلى
مقابر
في هذا الركن ، إنهم يبحثون عن
أربعة على الأقل مفقودين من هذه الكتلة وحدها ،
كما تقول فيكتوريا روبين التي تعمل مع
فريق الإنقاذ
لم نر شيئًا مثل هذا من قبل
من الصعب جدا بالنسبة لنا هي تقول
وليس فقط بالنسبة لنا ولكن بالنسبة لسكان
باروديانكا إنها مأساة كبيرة
بسبب  قوة غير منضبطة ولديها
رخصة للقتل ،
لذا فهذه فكرة فلاديمير بوتين عن
تحرير أمة شقيقة شقيقة ،
فإما أنه يفعل كل هذا لأنه
يحب الأوكرانيين أو كما يعتقد الكثيرون
لأنه مدفوع بالكراهية المتزايدة والغضب تجاه
ديمقراطيتهم الغربية المحبة.
في مقاومتهم ورفضهم الخضوع للسيطرة الروسية
وكتفكير لاحق رصاصة إلى
رأس البطل الثقافي الأوكراني
الشاعر العظيم تارا شيفتشينكو ، ولا حتى
التماثيل محصنة
وسط كل هذا الدمار
والإعدامات الموجزة ، يرفرف العلم الأوكراني
بفخر في الوسط.
مربع حسن التدبير يقوم هؤلاء
الجنود الأوكرانيون بسحب
دبابة روسية تم أسرها والتي تم حفرها
فيها ، ويقولون إنهم سيستخدمون هذا وأي شيء
آخر تركه الغزاة
لقتالهم في القرى في البلدات
في الحقول وعلى طول طريق العودة  إلى
الحدود الروسية